if you're a spider-man fan that's older
than like 15 there's a pretty strong
chance that somewhere
you've seen this maybe it was in a tv
commercial
or a spider-man themed workout video or
when he skated with tony hawk
tony hawk hey i skated with that guy or
in a magazine
picture stan lee a couple dozen of those
uh musical and most prominently
universal studios marvel islands of
adventure
for over a decade at least this was
spider-man's default look in the minds
of many fans
barring his shiny webbed appearance in
his theatrical debut
oh also my friend jacob's here hey i'm
here again these suits were distributed
to actors in the marvel personal
appearance group
which is still independent of disney to
this day
if you're an actor at this company
marvel will pay in advance and send you
a freshly cleaned costume in the mail
with instructions for where and when the
appearance is
when your flight will be where your
hotel will be etc it's like being a
hitman
except you make children and families
happier so you throw on a suit
get to car shows carnivals festivals
shopping mall appearances and whatever
else they need a spider-man captain
america wolverine or iron man or
whatever to appear
this particular iteration of the wall
crawlers duds were designed by betty
williams
an expert in theatrical costuming this
suit came about at the request of the
traveling web spinning performers
who had received complaints for the
better part of five years from fans at
public appearances
complaints about what you may ask was
the old suit itchy
did it ride up in the crotch a little it
was the eyes
you see it was 1992 and the original
eavesbrooks spider-man costume was
starting to look a little dated in a
post-todd mcfarlane society
kids would ask the performers why are
spider-man's eyes so small
although anyone subscribed to this
channel would know i'll go over it for
you anyway
spider-man as originally designed had a
plethora of webs all over his costume
and much squintier eyes than you'd
recognize him for today
it was the early 1960s and steve ditko
had created one of the most striking and
recognizable costumes in comics
after a groundbreaking three to four
year run on the book
ditko would leave spider-man in the
hands of its co-creator stan lee
and long time marvel artist john romita
as early as jon's first issue
you'd be able to notice some small
tweaks to spider-man's costume
the webs on the costume became a little
more sparse likely to speed up the time
it would take to pencil
there was the loss of the web wings and
as you'll notice spider-man's two-way
mirror lenses
also had a change of shape they had
become a little larger and more open
going forward this would be the
spider-man every artist would replicate
as the decades went by
but in 1988 readers were introduced to a
new look for the web slinger this was
spider-man through the lens of todd
mcfarlane a return to form
the reintroduction of the underarm webs
about three times as much webbing on the
red sections of spidey's costume
and the loss of the poor inker's annual
vacation days
and that just about brings us up to
speed after a few years of todd's mark
on the character
and a record-setting 2.65 million copies
sold
people had come to realize this as the
modern look for the character
and the personal appearance costumes
were lacking a few inches in the ocular
viewport department
doesn't sound like a lot but when it
comes to spider-man apparently size
matters
and so a new costume is born further
cementing spider-man's name and the
roster of those
who make the world of fantasy the most
exciting realm of all
we figured because we've seen it
everywhere this suit would still be
pretty common they must have produced
thousands of them for all these events
around the world
so why don't we have a line on more of
them well for one marvel appearance
group won't let actors keep the costumes
after their performance
and even worse what if during a bit of
amazing acrobatics you catch the suit on
a nearby rose bush at the park or snag
it in a mechanical component
on an atv that they have to drive at
universal for some reason
or get into a fist fight with the
wolverine actor because he's been
hitting on your wife all night and could
really use a lesson in manners
the company doesn't want to ruin the
illusion of real-life superheroes for
younger fans and maybe not every little
one could justify stitches or patches on
the suit as battle damage from a fight
with a thousand or something
so instead of repairing them the company
simply
shreds them and in the years since the
suit was popular it's been replaced with
a more modern version
that well i've gone on record is not
liking quite as much
[ __ ] ball i saw a [ __ ] so [ __ ]
[ __ ] it
was this suit his ass you all like
orange and gray that's the color of this
one
these logos have no character at all
it's just the generic ones you see on
everything also the eyes are like it's
[ __ ] stupid for no reason they can
just still be round i don't understand
the seam work is really sloppy around
the masks of these suits so it ends up
making the webs look horribly misshapen
so authentic universal spidey suits are
now few and far between
this costume design is genre media
seniors art brought to life and has
played such a crucial role in bringing
this character to the mainstream for
young fans like us
who grew up wishing we were the ones
wearing it it has such a charm in that
it looks so unabashedly
super but not something out of reach of
the possibility for someone to make
themselves at home
it feels like a really genuine look at
how spider-man would look in real life
and clearly that was an inspiration for
both of us so it's been a dream of ours
for many years to own one of these
ourselves
a fan tagged me on twitter last month to
tell me that someone was finally selling
this suit on ebay
for nearly three thousand dollars and i
was like nah man that's crazy i can't
spend that much on something like that
and then i thought about it my brain
went into a real haha
unless mode and i was like well what if
i get some help from the fans
so i asked everyone on twitter if they'd
be willing to throw some cash my way to
be able to get this thing and make a
video on it and they said they'd be
interested
and the suit got unlisted from ebay and
i was big mega sad because i got my
hopes up but then i messaged the seller
at ebay's private dms and asked if
someone had bought it and he said
someone was eyeballing it but that fell
through and then he gave me his personal
email
this guy's name was greg kelly who
specializes in crafting and selling
authentic movie props and costumes
comic books and nerdy antiques and he
also makes real-life james bond cars in
his spare time
big monkey i shared greg some video
a big monkey i showed greg some of my
videos including my previous one on the
history of spider-man suits and the ones
i've sewn myself
and he saw a kindred spirit in my
hyperactive nerdy ass
so he cut me a deal that if i put down a
deposit on the suit and raise the rest
of the money on kickstarter he'd give it
to me for 2800
and my amazing fans and friends came
through in only three days
next to my car this is the most
expensive thing i own and that's somehow
cool and really sad
i'm [ __ ] loser [ __ ] so let's see
how unboxing it went
i forgot a knife or not hey astute
viewers can you look hard enough you'll
know where he is so you can say hi
yourself
that don't do that don't actually i
would lit i would move
i'm torn between getting a knife and
watching you struggle no this is funnier
dear xavier sorry delayed a bit as i
goofed up when printing my own
postage at home please take care of this
one i've had so many of these but this
is the only only this
second 1992 versions uh very rare
regards greg oh cool well
this is the fun part
this is the whole reason you got it
right yeah
i'm like this is where your money went
youtube i'm a guest when you're home and
i'm not getting bubble wrap
ooh gang well you could see from the eye
yep this is about what i was imagining
for those yeah they have the soles on
the boots
it's folded in on itself here oh
now that's just for me a senior yeah
that's awesome
it has the zipper in the back
yeah here we
oh go at those eyes that's how you know
it's legit [ __ ] access to right now
the perfect lens template yeah oh yeah
you could just make any lenses you want
now solid yeah look hey look there's
rubber soles on it that's nice
that's good that's for walking around
theme parks made in china
there's tiny little little spots where
it's a little frayed
or like there's like a hole in it maybe
but i can stitch those up real
really like french fry i am wearing
history that's super cool
this feels it's trippy it's like uh
someone's found this there's like a
chin guard in here oh weirdly enough
like an elastic chin guard or something
getting your head in the neck is a
little spooky
because it it like it stretches but like
it doesn't look like it should stretch
more than it needs
to yeah because like the neck is pretty
tight when you see someone wearing it so
i'm a little paranoid about like [ __ ]
it up
i don't want to rip the neck on accident
but i
have to stretch it at least a little bit
to get my head in
you know what we just gotta not be
afraid of it
[Music]
you know the visibility's not too bad
i'd prefer like lenses because they're
just like sunglasses but this is
honestly like
pretty good visibility um it reminds me
this old deadpool costume i had when i
was like a little kid where it had like
white uh mesh fabric in the eyes there
too
all right yeah you just gotta kind of
like put it on like a sock
is the thing you just can't just like
pull it over in one
swift motion
i'm not sure you should probably get a
mannequin
just find a store that's like the shoe
size is like perfect actually
you know what if you guys are willing to
wait for a second i can go try and put
it on upstairs and come back down and
see
yeah go do that all right
it's cool it has like kung fu shoes
almost on the inside because there's
actually a part of the shoe that you
like that is attached to the inside
that's like a sock
uh i kind of see why the uh vratos would
complain that the visibility was a
little low
because the mesh is not like ideal and i
could see it kind of getting like
difficult to wear for someone with like
glasses my only thing
like that that raises the question
what's the difference between that and
the east brook spot
i suppose we'd have to get that one to
know for sure
you better be looking at the camera and
not me i can't this thing is truly a
marvel to look at
it's crazy seeing such a clear image of
it after not seeing one of these in
person since like 2009
are we gonna leave that in no we don't
gotta
i forgot that you wrote that this design
is definitely one of the most iconic
and error defining looks for the web
head it's undeniably the spider-man of
rometa senior's art
especially as look from like the mid 80s
onward personally i don't think you'd
get much closer to replicating what's on
the page
the colors are perfect the additional
webs help sell a modern
or 90s look that the suit was made in
mind with
but it doesn't go too far overboard to
the point of becoming a product of its
time
it's just as timeless as remitta spidey
the suit itself feels great to wear
the fabric's smooth and sturdy even
after all this time
the silk screened webs are so bold and
clean looking that they show up really
nicely on camera even at a distance
you can really tell this suit was
designed with photography in mind
there's a shoe inside including a top
half that keeps the soul from moving
away from your foot while you're jumping
which spidey performers complained about
early on as it would lead to accidents
or injuries
the back logo is fully embroidered and
sewn in so it stands out from the blue
section
even more with the bold black outline a
lot of people have asked me if the
gloves are removable because of this
seam on the arms but
that's all it is a scene it's a nice bit
of realism to imagine that's where the
real spidey would remove his gloves
though
the visibility isn't fantastic through
the white mesh however and
especially since i'm vision impaired it
can be a little hard to navigate in this
thing without contacts
if only had them fancy spider powers
lasik surgeries that tobyman's got
horizontal zipper is really easy to hide
and adds some believability to the
performers not having an
obvious way in and out of the suit as a
kid your imagination definitely pushes
you to see this as a seven-piece costume
sure it seems a little silly to be so
obsessed with owning this thing because
i already have plenty of spider-man
suits
some even a little better than this one
because i can go to the bathroom in them
or see through
the mask better but this thing is a
piece of history
for many people at a young age seeing
this help them believe in spider-man
would become attached to that character
and it unfortunately became a relic
because it was replaced by the new
universal studios suit or various other
more movie accurate ones
so few of these are left in existence
and having an authentic one is an
honor this specific costume means a lot
to me because it represents an important
chapter of the character's history
and an important era of the islands of
adventure park at universal
this costume was featured in the park
from opening day until the turn of the
decade when all the marvel characters
got a facelift alongside the updates to
the spider-man attraction
there's no going back to that period of
the park and it'd be a shame if all that
stuff was lost to time
now to display this thing properly i'll
need a mannequin and a nice glass case
so it's like my own personal museum
from the bottom of my heart to everyone
who donated thank you so much and i had
a blast filming all of the uh
the personal greetings
[Music]
never gonna let you down never gonna
mess around there are cars there
[ __ ]
that's one piece of history in the bag
you're next
boy
i don't remember what that was that was
a song in my head and i told you what it
was and i forgot what it was
there was no note or anything either i
really just that's going to be lost
[ __ ] we should have put a note there for
what that was
i think i just put it because i don't
think it even meant anything to the
video i just wanted to
it was on my mind so it went on to the
page
yeah okay all right well spiderman.com
by the way i think all this is going in
i'm very okay
[Music]
[Music]
you